the vast oceans of the popular video
game subnautica team with alien
creatures
some friendly and some deadly
while the game focuses on survival the
life forms of subnautica are amazing
even when they're trying to eat you
possessing fascinating biology bizarre
behavioral patterns and hidden mysteries
so for this entry into the archive we'll
embark on a documentary-style expedition
touring ecosystems from the shallows to
the abyssal trenches swimming in the
shadows of giants and evading predators
of the deep
this series will reveal the biology
behind these puzzling life forms and
investigate how they differ from life in
our own oceans
and although it's been a while since
this archivist has done any field work
i'll be diving into the perilous seas of
planet 4546b
myself to capture footage of these
magnificent life forms
so let's take the plunge together and
see what awaits us under the surface
beginning in the safety of shallow warm
waters we find that stable conditions
have led to a region crowded with varied
life
here you can encounter all manner of
undersea organisms
one of the first life forms we can spot
are the peepers or rather they spot us
with their enormous dinner plate like
eyes
these easily identifiable creatures have
evolved visual sensors capable of
discerning colors not just in clear
waters but in a variety of lighting
conditions this combined with their
surprising speed means that despite
being herbivores peepers aren't at the
bottom of the food chain
that distinction instead belongs to
these creatures the rather unfortunate
looking garry fish docile herbivores
that are remarkably slow the garry fish
make easy prey for most anything else in
these shallow waters
all ecosystems including the oceans of
earth need something at the bottom of
the food chain after all
other common herbivores on 4546b include
the bladder fish which swims by
contracting and expanding its
translucent bladder
in the unusual boomerang a horizontally
symmetrical oddity that possesses a
mouthful of sharp teeth to break down
coral
on the subject of coral the landscape of
the safe shallows is dominated by one
particularly unusual life form these
gargantuan tubes are large enough to
swim through and despite appearances are
very much alive
aptly named giant coral tubes they don't
look much like the coral we know on
earth
these tubes have evolved to filter
nutrients that flow through their center
and judging by their size and abundance
it's a strategy that has been quite
successful
gliding near the tubes is the elegant
rabbit ray the first of many ray species
we may encounter the undulating motion
that the rabbit ray uses to swim through
the clear seas is analogous to the
underwater movements of various types of
earth rays
but it's not the movement of the rabbit
ray that gives it its curious name
instead the rabbit ray's most defining
features are its twin orange appendages
that help it sense vibrations
these ear-like structures resemble the
ears of rabbits and so the aquatic
rabbit ray shares a name with an
otherwise dissimilar terrestrial
herbivore
beneath the shallows twisted network of
underwater caves
while exploring one as i was gathering
this footage i heard a strange noise
and then a fish exploded in my face
that short-lived creature was a crash
fish an evolutionary oddity that is
difficult to study due to its highly
frustrating habit of exploding when
anything gets close
while an animal exploding to defend its
territory might seem too outlandish to
evolve there's a model of such behavior
on our own planet though in common
certain species of ants have been
observed erupting into goo to block
tunnels when their nest is under threat
truly nature is highly unusual no matter
the planet
elsewhere in the caves the far less
bothersome shuttle bugs drift near the
stone walls shuttle bugs are challenging
creatures to make sense of with three
legs and three mandibles that have
evolved into thin like tentacles despite
looking slightly unsettling analysis
suggests shuttle bugs are too small to
be a threat to most organisms and have
instead adapted to feed on the waste
products of the ecosystem around them
leaving the caves you'll see our first
large species is waiting for us the
gasopods
these rotund leathery beasts resemble
earth manatees yet have a curious
defense that is all their own
although in no way hostile when
threatened gasopods will nonetheless
release a deadly cloud of underwater
mist which i can't recommend ingesting
chemical analysis of gasopods tells us
the poisonous compound comes from the
bulbous appendage at the end of their
tail
since gasopods are social creatures it's
even possible they use these clouds to
communicate with one another
but while the gasopods are the largest
creatures in the safe shallows they're
barely the tip of the proverbial iceberg
when it comes to planet 4546b
venturing into the vast kelp forest will
find a radically different environment
than the region we just left
here light is low thanks to the high
volume of creep vine plants creating a
hidden ecosystem just like kelp heavy
regions in earth's oceans
here and there clusters of creep vine
seeds cast shadows across the
environment like natural floodlights
i find myself wondering just what might
be hidden among the swaying fronds
that is a stalker the largest predator
that makes its home in the dense creep
vines
these fearsome customers possess a
series of dorsal ridges to help them
make tight turns and their long thin
snout is likely adapted for ensnaring
fish as it greatly resembles the
effective slender snouts of real-life
gariols
yet at the edge of the kelp forest one
stalker is behaving rather oddly
this stalker is picking up various
pieces of scrap metal with its snout
only to drop them after a short period
this behavior seems to serve no
practical purpose and indeed the
stalkers seem to simply have a fondness
for shiny objects puzzling as this
behavior might seem however the
barracuda a predatory earth fish is also
known to be attracted to shiny objects
because it's evolved to spot the silvery
glint of the fish it prefers to prey on
and when one considers the common prey
of the stalker this attraction to shiny
materials makes perfect sense
in the murky depths of the kelp forest
schools of fast-moving hoop fish light
up the dark with their vibrant coloring
a brief study of hoopfish anatomy
reveals they get their name from their
antennae which extends from the top and
bottom of their heads and bends around
their tails forming a hoop exactly why
these stunning fish possess such intense
and varied colors however is a mystery
on the subject of mysteries the last
fish of the kelp forest we'll see is
quite the enigma
meet the hoverfish a peaceful herbivore
that appears to hover on pads at the end
of its six legs using these strange
appendages the hoverfish glides on the
undersea currents and a man are quite
dissimilar to any other fish on the
planet it's surprising to learn
therefore that the hoverfish may
actually be a distant relative of the
non-descript bladder fish with their
legs actually a highly derived form of
the bladder fish's primitive vacuole
tubing it's the kind of creature that
could only exist in the kelp forest
just beyond the waving creep vines the
landscape gives way to an alien grassy
plateau
here the sandy terrain is almost
completely carpeted with blood grass as
the sea floor is too dense for creep
vines to take hold and in the open space
even larger life forms are on the prowl
at the edge of the grassy plateau a
strange cloud of sand is gathering
as we swim closer to the unexpected
turbulence a creature with a huge fanged
mouth lashes out
this is a sand shark a predator with a
distinctive hunting strategy
the sand shark burrows into the sand
then erupts out when unsuspecting prey
swims by ending the chase with a snap
from its massive jaws
with segmented body armor and six rows
of fearsome teeth it's little wonder why
these predators are so effective
and alien as their behavior might seem
some sharks on earth employ a similar
strategy in swimming along the sandy
floor near the shoreline in search of
food although they of course don't
possess the extreme tunneling abilities
of the sand shark
a common target of the sandshark's
brutal ambushes swims overhead
the spade fish doesn't look like much
from most angles but glimpse one from
above and you'll spot its defining
feature a single cyclopsian eye
closer analysis of the
suggests it feeds on the sea floor and
its single eye allows the spade fish to
spot predators above it its mottled
green coloration suggests it normally
hides among sea grasses like many fish
do on earth
when a spade fish wanders onto the
grassy plateaus however it is hopelessly
exposed
on the far side of the grassy plateau
would appear to be tiny floating islands
hang miraculously in the water
upon closer inspection these chunks of
rock are all supported by colonies of
the same curious life form
the floaters
transparent gelatinous blobs floaters
are at once oddly beautiful and slightly
silly looking analysis of these
creatures reveal they're actually
multiple microorganisms living in
symbiosis which we can compare to some
deep sea species of jellyfish the
floater's ability to suspend heavy
objects however remain something of a
mystery
swimming close by the floating islands
is a distant relative of the peeper
called the reginald the entire back end
of these oddly named fellows is composed
of one large fin and that finn's bright
coloration appears to be part of a
mating ritual
while it swims the reginald filters
algae and other plant-like material from
the water via four gill-like
forward-facing orifices
while this is a noteworthy adaptation
something looming behind the reginald
demands our attention
in the abyss beyond the edge of the
plateau the largest organism we've yet
to glimpse calls out through the deep
this is a reef back a leviathan-class
organism that exceeds lengths of 220
feet or 70 meters and is thankfully
quite friendly
swimming closer to these gentle giants
we can see they're unlike any life form
we've yet to glimpse
possessing a thick exoskeleton their
shells have become an oasis of life
adult reef backs can support many
ecosystems on their back including many
types of coral and small fish
and nearby this adult is a baby a much
smaller creature whose shell is not yet
ready to support an ecosystem like its
parents
i confess i spent some time just
watching these creatures drift in their
pods and listening to them call out to
each other with complex sounds that
suggest a surprising amount of
intelligence
[Music]
with the sun now getting low it's time
to venture deeper into the abyss and
enter the foreboding final biome of the
dunes
in this vast empty expanse life often
flocks near hydrothermal vents
these great fissures on the sea floor
release a rich chemical soup into the
water much like those that support life
in the depths of earth's oceans
but it's not life among the vents that
concerns me
a terrifying roar comes from above
a reaper leviathan strikes out into the
abyss
this aggressive apex predator possesses
four mandibles at the front of its maw
to drag in large prey and at 180 feet or
55 meters in length a hungry reaper
leviathan can take down almost anything
analysis of the organism's biology
suggests the roar emitted by a reaper is
a form of sonar meaning if you can hear
it the reaper can see you
thankfully it seems this reaper isn't
hungry
and as i watch the deadly leviathan
vanish into the darkness i realize i've
done enough field work for the day
the sun has now set on 4546b
yet the wonders of this planet continue
as in the low light various regions of
the sea are transformed by stunning
displays of bioluminescence
even the reef backpod from earlier is
now giving off a striking glow
this eerie beauty suggests there are
many hidden wonders we have yet to see
we'll venture further into the depths in
part two of the biology of subnautica
investigating the larger more extreme
and often more dangerous life of the
deeper biomes for now however our
journey is at its end
as always thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this entry please lend your
support to help make videos like this
possible by liking subscribing and
hitting the notification icon to stay up
to date on all things curious see you in
the next video